[Música]
[Aplausos]
estoy en sangre
en la pared
[Música]
marcas de pintalabios
y una chica en el baño
feliz
si eres
y tú de qué vas a qué bien yuta tú
a dos doble ramo en la piel despierto
suena profundamente
[Música]
el primer trago
y todo va rodado
todos
llevo a mis pies
[Música]
a veces
la ciudad
[Música]
sí
pero para nada para salir mal
mis
durango al fin en el trato y el esfuerzo
y la gran soy rock y en la 4 empiezo a
marear
[Música]
todo
torrox militar athar abbas
y el mundo
[Música]
bueno
la madera
salvar
él
llevemos los colores
a más
queremos ser más llévame a tu casa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
los terrores buenas
[Música]
me atrajo para nada para salir más
llevamos rocas no las ganas
veremos el bar llevar a tu casa muy
buenas tardes como los dobles rojos
[Música]
e
que pasamos buenas tardes no nos
imaginábamos aquí la verdad que siendo
de aquí nunca habíamos visitado lo que
había dentro de estas piedras hoy nos
encontramos todos solamente muchos de
nosotros de nosotros no muchos de
vosotros no conocíais pues eso que somos
de reus y vamos a intentar jugar un
poquito con la palabra abad ex qué es
de acontecimiento y bueno vamos a
aplicar el bueno en formato de dos
canciones maneras diferentes pues la que
puede una persona
en el corazón
y una de ellas pues es una idea un poco
mala que cuando estamos jodidos yo creo
que el corazón bombea también bastante
fuerte vamos a dar un poquito ya no
quiero verla más
ya no quiero verla más
ponme un trago nunca dijo la verdad
fue un engaño
su balazo por detrás me hace daño
[Música]
para más
[Aplausos]
[Música]
yo me voy a arrodillar pero no solo me
puede matar
qué
pero ya no quiero
[Música]
quiero verla más
sin abrazos no quiero
[Música]
el metal yo no quiero ver damas
no quiero verla
[Música]
puedo verlo
me emborracho
en el lugar
hoy en día
[Música]
seguramente
no quiero verla
[Música]
abrazos no quiero
[Aplausos]
[Música]
daño
no quiero verla
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no la puedo perdonar
pero si no quiero verla
no puedo más
no quiero verla
[Música]
no quiero
el mes año
[Música]
no quiero dejar más no quiero verlas
quiero verdad
[Música]
ahora vamos a hacer es mucho más que
estamos viendo rock and roll
parece mentira
el señor benet bueno luego los presentó
escribimos hoy me han escrito
[Música]
un libro mece los ojos ahogadas suspiro
admiro y escribo canciones estando
escondidos
no más
[Música]
pero
explorando frases de amar
mercedes
es un converso del carro
[Música]
acá
no hay mucho en sus bolsillos y apuestas
su vida las letras de un libro
no
nunca vas con amigos y ha empezado a
mover los hilos
[Música]
desde hace me hace toser a veces
cuando hacer la mira
esta que aumenta y me lo pienses
cambiando la realidad
[Música]
la lista
y ahí está
ah
d
i
[Música]
eso es
no vamos a despedir nos teníamos que
cantar la buena pero la buena no la
hemos traído hoy porque solo mira y
luego por internet había que traer
acústica y todo el rollo se llama nueva
blusera es una canción que escribimos
nosotros viajábamos pues tocábamos por
todo los bares de reus de tarragona
empezamos nuestra carrera en sakhir
todos los padres desde el cau hasta lo
que antes era el bebop
silestone bueno montón de sitios
era un poco pues la que
tratábamos la carretera que chupa vamos
bueno mira lo salvable ser abierto a
seguirnos por redes de valor
pues peña de móvil nosotros también nos
gusta mucho pero lo hacemos al revés la
siguiente canción y la última que vamos
a tocar
bueno dicen que el polvo perfecto
el latido la hicimos a la
llama al ritmo perfecto de un polvo
perfecto
sentís directos y mojadas
no somos
no sois vosotros somos nosotros tenemos
el doble rumbo ya en la cabeza nos
despedimos muchas gracias
[Música]
desde reducción o batería con 21 añitos
haciendo rock and roll mi señor en ávila
ha llegado
a
una vez más procedente de my boy con un
metro 78
49 kilos de peso sentido hasta el bajo a
rubén no exporta al bajo eléctrico
[Música]
a la guitarra no somos doble rombo estas
llamas no me puedes pedir arriba las
manos
[Música]
no me puedes pedir que me haga el
caballero que tenga tabacos caballos y
camellos buena bogadores que no me
entres sueños si no hay acción
soy un hombre sin sueño
el estado de nervios están preocupados
gastando mi tiempo en el rock and roll
cualquiera
las faldas cortas los vasos cargados
nuestros
[Música]
nunca son con la misma ropa que ayer
estaba en tus manos de arriba
[Música]
me importa decir lo que cayó la gente me
encanta pensar siempre contracorriente
en miami yo me odies por ser diferente
sin nada
[Música]
para siempre
pero si lo mismo
[Música]
la ropa bocado carne hace mi reputación
hoy mantengo
en calles con la misma ropa de ayer
damas y caballeros
[Música]
[Aplausos]
dijeron que cuelga en cualquier boca a
los escotes bajos las faldas gordas los
vasos cargados los besos son ron
hoy mismo
si estás lo haré con otra en un callejón
con la misma ropa y ayer estaba en tu
salón
webber sexto y un cabrón se cuelga en
cualquier boca los escotes bajos las
faldas cortas los vasos vámonos
y yo
con otras
con la misma ropa ya estaba
muchas gracias nos vamos
[Música]
i
ah
[Música]
estará bien